a woman just went viral on Tick Tock
this is so
sad this is so so sad it's a woman went
viral on Tick Tock giving a eulogy for
her
recently deceased father here's what she
had to say about her dad
but Dad please know that while I'm
grateful and highly aware of all that
you give in this family I still don't
miss you
when you died I feel like there was a
little something but it was
it was the idea of what you could become
I miss being able to Hope and wish that
one day you turn the corner and see the
world from my perspective I missed the
idea that one day you might help me
fight for the things that matter I
missed my fantasy of you
because when you decide it solidified
the fact that she'll never be what you
could have been but only what you are
and what you are is a racist
misogynistic xenophobic trump-loving
sister straight white man that is all
you will ever be to me and Dad before
you tell me to respect the dead please
remember that you disrespected and
disregarded the lives and deaths of
entire communities of people with your
ideology you told me to Never back down
so I won't you know for a fact that even
against you I'm not afraid to share my
peace you are everything I Aspire not to
be and I refuse to stand up here and
sing the Praises of a man who was the
Paradigm of white supremacy so I'll take
your racist mindset I'll take your money
and I'll take your advice and I swear to
God I will make this world a better
place not at all because of you but an
exact opposition to you
shocking of course but it really
shouldn't be shocking this is what
happens in totalitarian regimes in the
total state
this is what happens that children are
turned against their parents this is one
of the final stages of family breakdown
when the the regime when the ruling
ideology is able really to crack that
family in half and there has been a very
concerted effort for at least 60 years
now to destroy the American Family by a
strategic political left that has
succeeded every single step of the way
because it met with feckless resistance
from the right the right which which
also retreated from defense of the
family is the fundamental political unit
and embraced a bunch of platitudes about
how Society is really just about the
individual and do whatever you want just
don't make me pay for it and so that
they conceded the whole culture and they
conceded that fundamental unit now
you've got whiny kids attacking their
fathers which is nothing new but to do
so during a eulogy after the father has
died that that really would be
unusual and it's going to become more
and more usual unfortunately and this is
the kind of stuff that we are fighting
right now and so when candidates come up
in 2024 I suspect that the the lesson
that the establishment media wants us to
take from the midterms even in those
states where the vote count was kind of
weird you know and dragged on for a long
time and the results are somewhat
dubious they the clearly the conclusion
they want us to take is conservatives
just need to be a little bit more
conciliatory and a little bit more
moderate meet in the middle and stop
being so extreme okay stop talking about
things someone the other day I said on
this show
that a marriage is between a man and a
woman you know I said on this show that
Republicans who vote for the radical
redefinition of marriage to something
other than what it has been for all of
human history until five minutes ago
should not be in the Republican party
because they obviously don't want to
conserve anything and I have these
people post about me on social media
they said this is an extreme radical
far-right fascistic absolute Maniac who
says this
why because I expressed The View that
Barack Obama held in 2011. I expressed
The View that the current Democrat
president held
11 years ago
Joe Biden and Hillary Clinton same thing
that's how fast this is moving okay
and the the candidates who just say well
we're going to all come together in
Kumbaya that's not going to do it man
people are looking around they're saying
our country is being invaded that's what
Greg Abbott's saying our country doesn't
have borders anymore you've got Klaus
Schwab and the world economic Forum
saying Vivir destroy Gemini and juvenile
bugs you've got the the Educators saying
family is evil and we're going to
redefine the family and don't listen to
your awful parents we've got political
leftists talking about taking kids away
from parents if the parents want
transgender the kids and mutilate them
and sterilize them and now they're
admitting that these procedures that
they previously defended do sterilize
people and they are akin to torture
they're absolutely right about that that
those are the stakes in this election
okay and we need a big candidate with a
big Vision who is not just going to
focus on one little issue or this little
issue or even just domestic or just
foreign policy we need a candidate who's
going to take on the whole kitten
caboodle who is capable of that we will
find out during a primary process right
now head on over to goodranchers.com
Knowles you know I love spending the
holidays with my family and one of the
ways I like to do that is with delicious
meat from good ranchers as a special
gift to our listeners this holiday
season good ranchers is giving away two
Black Angus New York strip steaks free
with your order these are two 12 ounce
Steakhouse quality Cuts that's a 70
value for free you don't want to miss
this offer let me tell you why Black
Angus tastes better and is more tender
than any other beef black angus meat is
marbled in such a way that the fat is
distributed thinly and evenly this
marbling gives it a consistent flavor
that you don't get with other meats plus
the Black Angus from good ranchers is
hand cut and trimmed by expert butchers
so you know every piece is going to be
Exquisite while grocery store meat
prices are on the rise good ranchers is
dedicated to helping you save as much as
possible if you subscribe to good
ranchers today you can lock in your
price and avoid these insanely high
prices at the grocery store and get some
free meat while you're at it go to
goodranchors.com Knowles use code Knolls
at checkout for this special offer that
is goodranchers.com Knowles for two
Black Angus New York strip steaks with
your order for free good ranchers
American Meat delivered Greg Abbott
right now in Texas is setting himself up
to run for president in 2024. and he's
doing a pretty good job
Greg Abbott just announced on this
important issue of immigration
that he has invoked The Invasion clauses
of the U.S and Texas constitutions to
fully authorize Texas to fight back
against the influx of illegal aliens
this is a good idea I'm glad that that
Abbott is using this kind of language it
is an invasion that is what is happening
that is what illegal immigration is
we're talking about not just a million
legal immigrants a year which is a lot
of people but two million illegal
immigrants if you if you don't call that
an invasion I don't know what the word
Invasion means and Greg Abbott is now
legally calling it that so what does it
mean in practice
he says he's going to deploy the
National Guard to safeguard the border
and repel and turn back immigrants
trying to cross the border they'll
deploy the Texas Department of Public
Safety to arrest and return the Border
immigrants who crossed illegally uh
return them to the Border uh he'll build
a border wall in multiple counties On
the Border deploy gun boats to secure
the Border designate Mexican drug
cartels as foreign terrorist
organizations enter into a compact with
other states to secure the Border enter
into agreements with form and power
powers to enhance border security that's
not he's not going to be able to do that
the governor of Texas doesn't
conduct American foreign policy this is
why Trump focused on foreign policy in
his speech last night is because the
governors don't really have a say so
that one's pretty empty and provide
resources for Border counties to
increase their efforts to respond to the
Border Invasion okay so that all sounds
good but
where's the teeth where's the teeth of
this you know Ken cuccinelli
uh who's a great great conservative
leader and he was at DHS during the
Trump Administration uh he points out
that Governor Abbott has not in fact
invoked the full authority of an
invasion declaration he said that he's
being invaded but he's not blocking the
Invaders from coming and cuccinelli
points out until Abbott removes the
illegals back across the border and out
of the country this will just be a PR
stunt
and I tend to agree I mean this is this
is something that Trump is going to have
to prove that DeSantis is going to have
to prove that that
Greg Abbott is having to prove right now
enough of the words
I like I like the feisty zesty rhetoric
okay I like Clarity and rhetoric too I
mean that can serve a political purpose
but we need action
okay all the invasion declarations in
the world and a buck 50 will get you a
cup of coffee if you're not actually
taking the foreign Nationals entering
your country invading your country and
sending them back to their countries if
you're not doing that then you're not
really doing much of anything at all
and I suspect this is also why Trump
kind of tones down his announcement last
night
is he didn't want to be accused of just
Bluster
okay you can Bluster your way through a
first campaign but then you've got to
get a little bit more serious and Trump
put a lot of wins on the scoreboard all
right let's not downplay that Trump got
Roe v Wade overruled yeah he's the
biggest conservative win in my lifetime
maybe you have the century
and and you've got a lot of other wins
too but that that zesty rhetoric is is
only going to play for so long then you
need results
you know the rest of the show is going
to continue now when we talk about a
story that really has fascinated me the
FTX collapse this is the second largest
crypto Exchange in the world it was run
by the second largest donor to the
Democrat Party during the midterm
elections and it's this guy who prattles
on and on and on about what a wonderful
guy he has sent Sam backman freed and uh
he he's he's this uh sort of holier than
now lib this preening virtue signaler
and it turns out he's one of the biggest
scam artists of the century the whole
thing collapsed I don't know anything
about crypto so I'm interviewing Eric
Voorhees who is who is one of the OG is
truly one of the experts and leaders in
the whole Space we've got that coming up
on the member block if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]